leaving windsor in the midst of what is
undoubtedly one of the world's most
high-profile legal battles
but today another twist
the lawyers for prince andrew filed
legal documents claiming the woman
accusing him of sexual assault may
suffer from false memories
virginia defray says she was 17 when the
duke of york allegedly sexually abused
her after years of fighting she wants
her day in court
the prospect of a trial which could take
place as soon as september prompted
buckingham palace to strip andrew of his
military titles and royal patronages
the prince has strenuously denied the
allegations of 21 years ago
and so now the duke of york's legal team
wants to interview his accuser's husband
robert to face questions about the
couple's finances and how he met his
wife in 2002
they also want to ask her psychologist
dr judith lightfoot to disclose any
medications she prescribed to defray
in return virginia duffray's lawyers
have asked to interview prince andrew's
former personal assistant and a woman
called shukri walker who it's claimed
saw the duke with a young girl in a
london nightclub
a lawyer who has represented some of
jeffrey epstein's victims says he's not
surprised about this line of defense
if you recall during the trial of glenn
maxwell her trial team tried to assert
those allegations as well and put
certain psychologists and therapists on
the stand but the jury saw through those
allegations
and i would hesitate to say
it's hard to falsify uh
photographic evidence that the duke was
with ms dufrey in the photograph with
glenn maxwell
elizabeth loftus gave evidence during
the maxwell trial and says people can
confidently recall events
that never happened
if
things
did not happen the way she is saying if
they did not happen
then there are two reasons why she might
be saying it one is that she's
lying and it's an intentional lie the
other is that she has come to believe it
and she has false memories
and
both of those remain possibilities
in this case
there are still many legal steps in this
process before a potential trial there
will be other arguments from the duke's
lawyers to block aspects of his personal
life being aired in open court but this
has already been a hugely damaging week
for the queen's second son
as he faces this legal battle as an
ordinary citizen without the arm of the
royal family in zaman rashid sky news